zum ersten mal haben wir auch
tatsächlich einen veranstalter bei und
es geht um das thema ausgefallene
konzerte partys wie geht es weiter
und ich begrüße markus krampe ein
schwergewicht in der in der
schlagerszene manager ist auch
veranstalter von wirklich großen von von
partys von ja hauptsächlich es
eigentlich schön dass sie da sind zuerst
die frage sie mussten ja oder sie müssen
ja viele veranstaltungen absagen bis zum
31 august darf ja keine
großveranstaltung wegen corona
stattfinden wie stellt sich die lage aus
ihrer sicht da haben sie schon
ausweichtermine gefunden oder erstatten
sie das geld wie ist da ihre planung ja
also im moment ist es ja so dass wir
über 20 veranstaltungen in diesem jahr
ins nächste jahr legen mussten konnte
das war natürlich ein riesengroßer
verwaltungsaufwand weil natürlich nicht
nur die location mitspielen muss dann
auch die künstler wir haben ungefähr 100
künstler auf und veranstalten also nicht
nur schlager und partykünstler sondern
wir machen auch die größten 90er partys
europaweit glaube ich und da ist
natürlich immer auch das problem dass
die künstler im internationalen kalender
haben
und ja das haben wir aber geschafft und
ja relativ kurzer zeit steht fest dass
wir alles neue termine gefunden haben
und werden unsere verhandlung bis auf
kleine ausnahmen also die partie auf
schalke und auch die 90er party auf
schalke werden wohl noch stattfinden
wenn die politik dann uns das ganze auch
erlaubt anfang september könnte mir das
mal erklären also sie haben hallen
gebucht sie haben künstler gebucht jetzt
findet nicht statt müssen sie die hallen
trotzdem bezahlen müssen die künstler
trotzdem honorieren wie ist da so die
rechtliche lage überhaupt also es ist
von bis das kommt natürlich immer auf
den persönlichen kontakt auch glaube ich
an den mann zu den künstlern auch zu den
managern hat und auch zu den location
betreibern
grundsätzlich glaube ich habe alle
gemerkt dass wir in einem boot sitzen
und das wenn da irgendwie einer quer
schießt das natürlich auch viele große
veranstalter ein problem bekommt wir
haben z
in diesem jahr ungefähr 30 veranstaltung
mit über 500.000 besuchern die wir
gehabt hätten
und das ist natürlich in der branche
ganz relativ groß und natürlich
versuchen wir uns mit allen irgendwie so
zu stellen dass es auch funktioniert und
so erwarten dass natürlich auch von
unseren partnern das hat im großen und
ganzen auch geklappt
es gab zwei drei problemfelder dann ein
bisschen nachjustieren mussten aber auch
das aber geregelt und wie ist das jetzt
also sie sagten die veranstaltung finden
dann im nächsten jahr startklar da wird
es ja wahrscheinlich dann auch wieder
partys geben zurzeit ja zurzeit noch ein
absolutes tabu ich weiß auch gar nicht
wann in diesem jahr wieder richtig
gefeiert werden kann clubs und
diskotheken sind ja auch noch
geschlossen
wie ist das wenn jetzt zum beispiel ein
zuschauer sagt ich weiß gerade im
nächsten jahr bin ich dafür zu alt oder
da möchte ich nicht dran teilnehmen wie
gehen sie dann vor
also es war ja am anfang eine relativ
rechtsunsicherheit oder eine
unsicherheit wie die bundesregierung
jetzt auch uns vorgaben macht und
ursprünglich wurde dann ja und das ist
glaube ich das weist der anwalt in der
sendung besser ist es eine gut will
aktion der kunden dass sie gesagt haben
komm wir verzichten auf die
rückerstattung dem eventuell gutscheine
oder nimmt die gutscheinlösung in
anspruch aber mir ist sehr wohl bewusst
dass wir als veranstalter natürlich
dafür gerade stehen müssen die ticket
gelder auch zurückzuerstatten das ist
nicht immer ganz einfach weil wir
natürlich mit während ticket anbietern
arbeiten auch vielen großen namhaften
und ja die haben sich am anfang auch ein
bisschen quer gestellt haben gesagt nach
dem motto lasst uns erst mal abwarten
wie die rechtliche situation ist jetzt
sollte ja vor kurzem eine entscheidungen
der bundesregierung gefällt werden das
als ich glaube ich um ein paar tage
verzögert oder soll jetzt am 15
gemacht denn wir sind am anfang her
gegangen und haben die gelder
rückerstattet direkt und alle die sich
jetzt bei uns melden weil natürlich wenn
die kunden beim ticket anbieter nicht
weiterkommen ähnlich wie ihr anwalt das
vor kurzem empfohlen hat melden die sich
bei uns als veranstalter und wir
arbeiten das gerade sukzessive ab und
der stadt natürlich den ticket gelder
zurück wollen wir doch gleich ankämpfen
der wurde von ihm gerade zum
wunderschönen anmoderiert gleich mit
dazu nehmen also tatsächlich haben wir
hier auch schon
viele zuschauer auch beraten tatsächlich
geht es dann darum muss sich einen
gutschein akzeptieren an kempkens hat
festgestellt dass die lesung dieses so
genannten gut steigen gesetzes noch mal
vertagt worden ist das heißt zur zeit
gibt es diese gutscheinlösung noch nicht
man kämpfe etwas ist der neueste stand
genau das ist der fall ist es natürlich
jedem selber überlassen ob er das
akzeptiert also ist ja auch nichts
dagegen einzuwenden wenn der kunde von
sich aus sagt ich möchte eben den
veranstaltete unterstützen ich will das
geld im moment noch nichts zurück haben
sondern ich schaue mir den markt an
ich lasse mich auch das ersatzkonzert
ein oder so das ist vollkommen okay und
ich bin auch gar nicht unbedingt dazu
aufrufen das eben nicht zu machen
sondern es geht ja darum was will der
kunde eigentlich was will der
verbraucher was will der ticket inhaber
von daher ist es absolut legitim dass
eben auch zu stunden und eben noch nicht
zurück zu verlangen nur die leute die
eben zurück verlangen die haben eben den
anspruch drauf und da meine ich das ist
genau richtig ist wieder veranstaltet
jetzt erreicht sagt dann reagieren wir
auch und dann arbeiten wir das ab und
genau das ist richtig so und das ist
auch gut so und was die ticket lösung
selber also die gutscheinlösung für die
deutschen tickets anbelangt da brauchen
wir ja keine eu abstimmung wie bei den
reisen sondern das kann auch
bundesdeutscher ebene gemacht werden und
da müssen wir sehen wie das weitergeht
da gibt es ja so ein paar anträge auch
von verschiedenen anderen partei das ist
ja die regierungsparteien die das eben
ins in den bundestag eingebracht haben
das sollte eigentlich letzte woche ja
abschließend beschlossen werden oder
beredet werden aber da war eben noch
beratungsbedarf an es gibt ja auch viel
kritik daran
und da müssen wir mal sehen wie das
weitergeht wir haben tatsächlich auch
schon die unsere zuschauer beraten wie
ich jetzt vorgehen wenn ich jetzt ein
ticket habe also zum beispiel wo wir uns
doch mal durchgehen also ich gucke auf
das ticket drauf und stelle dort fest
herr krampe ist mit seiner firma der
veranstalter das heißt ich möchte müsste
mich auch an herrn krampe nicht an ihn
persönlich werden aber an seine firma
wenn ich das geld zurückhaben will
wie ist das herr krampe gesagt haben
dass von angedeutet da haben sich so die
vermittler also die ticket aussteller so
ein bisschen angestellt oder wie
er ist letztlich dann aus ihrer sicht
zuständige auf meiner sicht sind sie es
ja dann gebe ich ihm recht da kann man
noch nicht wieder sprechen wir sind die
veranstalter und im endeffekt auch der
geldempfänger allerdings ist der der
erstes vielleicht alles erklären der der
das geld einnimmt ist der ticketanbieter
und schüttet an uns aus das sind auch
noch nicht alle gelder ausgeschüttet
worden an uns so dass es da
handlungsbedarf gabe und redebedarf dass
wir erst mal mit den partnern gesprochen
haben gesagt passt mal auf die kunden
wenden sich jetzt an uns die wollen ihr
geld zurück haben wir müssen uns
ausschütten also müssen das auch von
euch erstmal bekommen und das ist jetzt
passiert bei den meisten und wird wie
gesagt so christina abgearbeitet
allerdings muss ich auch dazu sagen es
sind gar nicht so viele leute die ihr
geld zurückhaben möchte sind immer
härtefälle die sagen ich habe zu dem
termin irgendwie eine hochzeit oder
tatsächlich den runden geburtstag oder
es war ein junggesellenabschied wo wir
deswegen für die karten gekauft haben
den gibt es jetzt ja leider nichts
deswegen wollen wir die karten
vielleicht umtauschen
es war aber auch ganz häufig der fall
dass viele leute geschrieben habe was
man auch wir verstehen uns als
veranstalter wir haben vollstes
verständnis dass es jetzt ins nächste
jahr gelegt werden muss und deswegen
behalten wie die karten beziehungsweise
neben die gutscheinlösung vielleicht
eine andere veranstaltung also der wenn
man das in prozent beziffern würde ist
bei uns der rücklauf noch nichtmals bei
5 prozent aller aller ticketkäufer und
das ist auch sehr gut so glaube ich
schon auf das thema das die leute halt
zwischen dem vermittler und dem
veranstalter hin und her geschoben
werden
sie haben gerade gesagt das geld ist
auch noch gar nicht bei ihnen angekommen
ist natürlich dann auch schwer das geld
zu überweisen
hängt das dann so lange beim beim ticket
aussteller weil die halt sagen naja wie
ist wir können nichts dafür da ist muss
der veranstalter gerade stehen aber wenn
sie das geld noch nicht haben ja wo ist
das geld dann also es ist so dass wenn
sie ticket kaufen dass das dass das
natürlich erst mal mein ticket anbieter
landet der das geld für uns vereinnahmt
und nach einem gewissen zyklus entweder
monatlich je nachdem wie wir es
vereinbart haben wie die ausschüttungen
bekommen und da gab es tatsächlich
schwierigkeiten dass einige
ticketanbieter auf sich uns gegenüber
gestreut haben
haben gesagt moment wir behalten das
geld jetzt erstmal wir wissen ja noch
gar nicht wie die rechtliche situation
aussieht
ich habe dann entschieden dass wir das
geld bekommen möchten und dass wir die
kunden zufrieden stellen möchten wir
sind dann auch teilweise in vorleistung
getreten wenn leute hier geschrieben
haben uns sichern uns gewendet haben
dann gesagt wir möchten oder geld zurück
dann haben wir das gemacht weil wir wie
gesagt wir sind jetzt seit 15 jahren am
markt und im endeffekt bleibt an uns
hängen man kennt den namen der
verantwortung sagt die haben uns hier
für apple geben das geld nicht
zurückgezahlt das wollte ich vermeiden
und deshalb haben die allen gästen jetzt
die zusage gemacht dass wir das geld
zurückerstatten und das ist wie gesagt
gerade daran dass auch so zu tun
jetzt haben wir wahrscheinlich noch ein
paar tage zeit bis diese gutscheinlösung
in kraft tritt muss ich mich an kempkens
jetzt sofort am besten an markus krampe
wenden bevor dieses gesetz dann wirklich
verabschiedet ist oder er ist das noch
habe ich ja noch ein bisschen zeit also
die gesetzliche regelung soll ja
tatsächlich diese tickets umfassen
und wenn das tatsächlich in kraft tritt
dann würde es im bundesgesetzblatt
verkündet werden und einen tag später in
kraft treten und ab dann wäre eben diese
gutschein möglichkeit gegeben
und wer eben das nicht akzeptieren will
der sollte tatsächlich sich an den
veranstalter direkt wenden und wenn wir
eine rampe gerade sagt er zu recht wir
zahlen sofort aus es ist wunderbar
wir erleben wie der praxis wenn es
andere veranstalter die das eben also
auch die die kunden auch sehr verein und
hier irgendwie die leute hinhalten und
da irgendwie völlig falschen rechtlichen
hinweisen auch in dem wir teilweise
geschrieben wird wir müssen ihnen einen
gutschein ausstellen dürfen gar nicht
bezahlen und so was alles lesen praxis
in so emails und das ist einfach nicht
in ordnung und deswegen ist das umso
besser dass sie hier ein veranstalter
auch hier ganz deutlich sagen ich bin
der kommunikation wichtig ich finde es
wichtig auch den kunden gegenüber und
man sieht auch den erfolg wir sehen doch
hier ein fairer veranstalter der hier
sauber das abwickelt er hat hier eine
rückzahlungsquote von fünf prozent das
ist doch wirklich absolut erträglich und
das liegt auch daran dass sie gut
kommuniziert wird und wenn die
veranstalter global das so machen haben
wir auch gar kein problem wenn die
veranstalter aber mauern
dann werden die dann werden natürlich
die kunden auch sauer und dann kommen
sie nämlich zu den anwälten und sagen
jetzt müsst ihr klaren ja und dann gibt
es ja auch gar keine andere möglichkeit
denn es ist ja nicht etwa so dass die
anwaltschaft insgesamt wild auf solche
klagen ist das ist gar nicht der fall
sondern man will einfach eine faire
lösung für die kunden
letzte frage noch an markus krampe wie
ist es sie stellen sich jetzt hier hin
sie sind natürlich auch bekannt sie sind
natürlich auch keinen lohn
ich habe mir mal so angeguckt wer
überhaupt bei so vielleicht nicht bei
den ganz großen konzerten aber sogar die
mittelgroßen konzerten so veranstalter
sind das wird zum teil so ein bisschen
wie home office also das sind halt keine
großen firmen die auch noch nie in der
öffentlichkeit stehen die haben zum teil
auch gar kein impressum auf ihren seiten
wie ist denn da was sagen sie auch
ticket besitzern wie geht das weiter
oder gibt es dann welche die einfach
abtauchen und dann konkurs anmelden wie
sehen sie die zukunft
ja das hat man ja sogar schon vor
corinna gesehen dass es immer wieder
schwarze schafe gibt die einfach denkt
nach komme ich mache mir so eine
schlagerparty oder enge partie kündigen
paar künstler an und bieten eine
location und mal was passiert verkauften
karten und ist ganz häufig so passiert
das dann kurze zeit später auf einmal
kam ja moment nähe das rechnet sich
alles doch nicht und wir sagen dass ab
und auf einmal waren die veranstalter
nicht mehr auffindbar
deswegen kann nicht nur jedem raten wenn
er sich ein ticket kauft sich auch ein
bisschen damit auseinander zu setzen
wäre vielleicht dahinter steckt sind das
leute die jahrelang am markt sind oder
die auch schon erfahrungen haben in
diesem bereich bei der veranstaltung zu
machen ist nicht so ganz einfach man
steht morgens auf und sagt auf einmal ja
komm ich kann das das ist glaube ich
eine antrag wie viele andere auch die
man lernen muss und wo man auch
jahrelange erfahrungen mit haben muss
und dann kann man das auch vernünftig
machen ja warnt markus krampe
partyveranstalter und auch manager und
der kennt sich aus noch eine letzte
frage thema ballermann
sie veranstalten natürlich auch mallorca
partys wie geht's am ballermann weiter
wird da in diesem jahr noch irgendwann
gefeiert was es da ihre einschätzung
also wir haben ja einen durch unsere
künstler die wir auch im megapark jochen
könig zum beispiel vor ort haben wir
betreuen ja michael wendler oder auch
mehr julia und viele andere bin ich
natürlich im engen austausch mit den
betreibern der locations und vor zwei
drei wochen würde ich sagen weil ich bin
noch sehr bedrückt und da haben wir alle
gesagt wir glauben nicht dass dieses
jahr noch irgendetwas passiert seitdem
lockerungen nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch auf mallorca sind alle ja
ich würde mal sagen leicht euphorisch
das vielleicht im mitte august
vielleicht im september noch ein
bisschen gefeiert werden kann
ja wir wissen dass alle nicht wie es
ausgeht wir hoffen natürlich nur ich
würde mich für jeden freund der gerne so
eine art von partys machen auf die
künste natürlich dass das noch klappt